Here you go.
Can I help you, sir? How's it going,
man? Um shalom. Good and you?
Okay. I I I don't know. I wasn't really
trolling in the comments. All I was
asking
Let me Let me clarify. All If you
actually scroll up, all I was asking was
if you believe in keeping the Well,
there's obviously a reason why. Okay,
now before we get into that Okay.
>> child of the Most High, what do you
believe
regarding the Trinity?
So, from what I understand
um
In 1 Colossians 1:15, it says that
Yeshua
>> There is no 1 Colossians. It's
Colossians 1:15. Yeah, sorry. In
Colossians 1:15, it says Yeshua is
Can I finish the verse with you? He's an
image of the image of the invisible God
and firstborn of all creation. Yeah. So,
my analysis of if he's created, that
means he's not the creator.
>> Firstborn doesn't mean that. Okay. Um
Hold on. Before you move on, calm down.
You just quoted Colossians 1:15. Yeah.
And you assume firstborn means he's the
first created. That's not what it means
contextually. You know how the word
firstborn is used in the Bible? No, I
don't. I've only been studying the Bible
for a month now. So, I I don't
>> Okay, good good good. I want to help you
now. Yeah, no. I I have and I don't want
like I don't want to come up here
thinking you're I'm a child of Satan cuz
I've been really trying to study the
Bible. No, I know. I know. But the only
question that I was asking in the
comments is I see a lot of Christians
out here preaching this um one saved
always saved doctrine and I Forget about
one saved always saved.
>> Yeah, so it's not true, right? Like can
we agree with that?
>> Forget about that one right now. You're
appealing to the law. You mean the law
of Moses, right? I always say 10
Commandments and eating clean and the
Sabbath. What's your background? Keeping
the Sabbath. So, if you're an
anti-Trinitarian, you're either an
Adventist, what are you?
I'm I don't associate to anything. I
just I keep the 10 Commandments and eat
clean and keep the Sabbath. You know, I
want to kiss your head. You're a young
man. I want to help you. I don't want to
attack you. So, just listen to me.
>> Okay. I'm sorry. There is no one who
reads the Bible
neutrally
and concludes that if you're reading the
New Testament that now I'm going to keep
the 10 Commandments unless you have some
external influence. Who has influenced
you? Be up front with me. Who have you
been watching? No, I actually don't
watch anyone. From from what I read with
you in Matthew and I'm trying to be as
far I know it doesn't seem like that,
but when I read the Bible in Matthew 5
it says Yeshua Hamashiach didn't abolish
the law.
>> Okay, even that word Yeshua, who taught
you Jesus' name? You see now you're
exposing yourself.
I'm not trying to Well, friend, be
patient. Okay. You just exposed that
you're lying, which is fine. I'll
forgive you because Yeshua Hamashiach
who taught you that his name is Yeshua
Hamashiach?
Well, doesn't that
>> Hebrew?
I do not. Doesn't that mean Yeshua?
>> Oh, wait, wait, say it again. I want to
hear that. Do you read Hebrew?
>> I I do not read Hebrew, no. Okay. Do you
read Greek?
I mean, I go to BibleHub. I don't read
it, but I try to study it.
>> Do you read Greek? No, I do not read
Greek. Because the New Testament that
you're reading is not in Hebrew. Okay,
now you show me on BibleHub or whatever
hub where the word Yeshua Hamashiach is
is is found in the New Testament.
>> I cannot. So now let's be honest. Don't
hide. No, I'm not trying to. Where did
you learn
Yeshua Hamashiach? Who's teaching you?
Who's influencing you?
>> I I would say from more of the Torah
observant community. I've heard you
before say Yeshua.
>> No, I have not My friend, I'm not here
to lie or anything. I'm just I'm just
trying to understand a better grasp on
the Bible.
Yeah. Just a couple minutes ago you just
said we got you recorded. No, I don't
listen to anyone. I don't watch. I just
read. No, but
>> don't admit it. You are being influenced
by
these Hebrew Roots movement, right?
So I I don't watch anyone. You said when
you asked me do you watch them it's like
someone is specific. No, I just heard it
around. A lot of people say Jesus' name
was Yeshua Hamashiach. It means Yeshua
saves. Yeah. Now let's go back. I want
to work with you because I want to
change the broadcast. I hope you don't
mind. I want to work with this young
man. If you've only been studying for a
month and let's see how sincere you are.
Do you have your Bible ready? I do. I I
it in front of me here. Now what did
they teach you about Father, Son, and
Holy Cuz you just said Jesus is the
first creature, right?
Uh from Colossians 1:15.
>> Yeah, but 1:15, the word firstborn, have
you finished the context?
No, I I I I have not. Can you explain
that to me in detail?
>> Yeah, can you go to Colossians 1? Yeah,
I'm right here.
Read 15 for me.
Who is in the likeness of the invisible
Elohim and the firstborn of all
creatures.
>> There you go, reading even a butchering
of the Greek. It's not likeness of
Elohim. So, here you are being
influenced. You didn't even pronounce
the word Elohim, you said Elohim.
I tried to pronounce it Elohim, but I'm
>> Okay, but I'm going to give you $10
million to show me that when Paul wrote
this, and he wrote in Greek, he used
Elohim as opposed to the word Theos.
I can I mean, we can look at it right
now. I'm pretty sure Wait, I Listen, can
I just say this before we continue? I've
been watching for a bit now, and I
really
you study a lot, so I'm trying to learn
the best that I can. So, I'm
>> what I'm trying to teach you is
>> Please don't try to like attack me cuz
I'm just trying to understand.
>> you, I'm teaching you. Dude, calm down.
I can see you're young. That's why if I
was attacking, I'd insult you. What I'm
trying to do is I'm trying to be used by
the Holy Spirit to have the Spirit purge
you of all this misinformation Great.
that you got a lot of bad learning.
First of all, it's not likeness, it's
image, icon. The image of the invisible
God, and it's not written in Hebrew,
it's written in Greek. And the word for
God in Greek would be Theos. Theos.
>> What translation are you reading that
said Elohim? My translation come from
the ISR Scriptures. Exactly.
>> Scripture. It comes from South
Institute Scripture Research, ISR. Ah,
so now you gave it away. This is who
you've been listening to.
Good, that's all right. I'm not upset at
you. Now, do you have any other Bible
besides that garbage that you're
reading? I mean, I can go to the Codex
uh
I can go to the Codex
>> go to Codex Sinaiticus or Alexandrinus
or Vaticanus cuz you can't read the
Greek.
Do you have any other translation
besides that trash that you're eating?
What translation would you be looking
for would be What do you have? I don't
know what you have. I mean I can go to
biblehub.com it has KJV Go to
biblehub.com read okay if the if
Shakespearean English is too difficult
go with NIV.
Colossians 1:15 start there. Get there
and let's read. Okay.
All right when you get there.
>> I I appreciate the the time that you're
taking my friend I really do.
>> I'll I'm going to change entire session
just for you cuz my eyes are on you now.
So 1:15 you said?
Who is in the image of the invisible God
the firstborn of every creature. Now
before you move on. Uh-huh. You see the
difference between how that translation
what you read?
I do. Who is in the likeness. Likeness
implies not the actual thing that we're
trying to understand here. I see. The
image now but even image obviously if
I'm in your image then I bear your
likeness but we want to go with what the
word says. Now
firstborn every creature
Now read 16 and 17 to see what firstborn
means and doesn't mean. Okay. So I'll
read 15 16 and 17. Who is in the image
of the invisible spirit the firstborn of
every creature.
>> Not invisible spirit. Where did you get
spirit? So invisible God sorry. I'm I'm
sorry my bad. The firstborn of every
creature for by him were all things
created that are in heaven and are that
are in earth visible and invisible
whether they by thorns or dominions or
principalities or powers all things are
created by him and for him. Okay now
pause right there. Okay.
>> It says for by him all things are
created. And it tells you everything
heaven earth visible and invisible
dominions stones principalities powers.
And then it says all things were created
>> [clears throat]
>> by him and for him but now 17.
And he is before all things
and by [clears throat] him all things
consist.
Okay you can stop there. Okay. When it
says he is before all things
what does all things mean there?
That would imply
uh
a necessary being that doesn't need
anything to exist like before all
things.
>> Well, you got you got the idea, but all
things means all creation, right? So, he
is before all creation?
>> Yes, that's what this says right here.
Okay, so if he's before all creation,
that means he's not part of creation,
right?
Correct. So, if you're not part of
creation, how can you be a creature?
That means you're uncreated, right?
Repeat that one more time.
If you are before all creation, that
means you're not part of creation,
right?
Correct, because then you'd be
contingent.
Not only contingent.
You would then have to create yourself
because it said Jesus created all
creation, all things, and he sustains
all things. So, well, if he created all
things and he exists before all things,
and he sustains all things, and all
things means all creation, that means he
was there when there was no creation,
right? Correct. That would imply that.
Yeah.
How can he be a creature?
He cannot then.
All right, so then firstborn cannot mean
the firstborn created. So, let me now
show you what firstborn can mean. Okay.
Go to your Old Testament. Go to 1
Chronicles 5:1-2.
1 Chronicles 5:1-2. Now, the sons of
Reuben, the firstborn of Israel, for he
was the firstborn, but for for as much
as he's defiled his father's bed, his
birthright was given unto the son of
Joseph, the son of Israel, and the
and genealogy is not to be reckoned
after the bright bright but birthright,
sorry. For Judah prevailed above his
brethren,
and of him came the chief ruler, but the
birthright was Joseph. Okay, now Joseph
was son number 11, right?
Uh don't ask me these questions cuz I
don't know what but
If you read the genealogy, Jacob had 12
sons. Okay. The 11th son was Joseph. His
first son was Reuben. Reuben. So, Reuben
was born first, so he's the firstborn in
the sense of being born first, right?
Correct. Of Israel.
>> But, the birthright was given to Joseph.
So, in status, Joseph became firstborn.
Cuz in the Bible, the term firstborn can
mean the one born first, who is the
heir, cuz if you're the firstborn,
the inheritance is yours, and who is
supreme in status, cuz he is the head
over the siblings, right?
Yes.
Okay, now, when it says Joseph was given
the birthright of the firstborn,
it cannot mean he's the one born first,
because Reuben was the one born first,
right? Yes.
So, then what does it mean that Joseph
is the firstborn?
From a high ar- high ar- how do I say
that word? Like a
Yes, from that kind of standpoint.
>> He is the head of his brothers, and the
inheritance is his, right? Yes. So, now
you see the term firstborn doesn't
always refer to the one born first. The
term firstborn can refer to a status
that I am firstborn in terms of status.
I am supreme, and the inheritance is
mine, right? Correct. Now, let me give
you another example. Go to Psalm 89.
Psalm 89.
When you get there, let me know.
89. Yeah, I'm here. You there? Yeah.
Read 19 and 20. Psalm 89, verses 19 and
20. Then thou speak speaketh in a vision
of uh in thy holy one, and in the
saideth, "And I have laid upon one that
is mighty. I have exalted one chosen out
of the people.
And I have found David my servant, with
my holy oil I have anointed him.
Okay, so who's he talking about?
And those speak in the vision of the
holy one and the saideth I'm pretty sure
I will I'm just guessing here. I would
assume that he's talking
>> It's right there, man. Don't guess. Read
it. Who's he talking about?
I have found David my servant.
So, who is he talking about?
David. Okay, keep that in mind, David,
right? Now, when you read, you don't
need to turn there, but when you read 1
Samuel 16, David was the youngest of
Jesse's eight sons. He was the youngest
of eight, not the first son,
and he wasn't the first king of Israel.
Saul was king before him. You with me?
Yes, Saul. Okay. But now, notice what it
says about David, cuz he's talking about
David. Read Psalm 89:26-27.
Psalm 89:26 or 27.
He shall cry unto me, thou art my
father, my ya, and rock of salvation. My
what?
My salvation. No, you said ya. Didn't
say ya. Stop adding to the text.
>> Sorry, okay. My God, and the rock of my
salvation. Why are you adding words to
the text?
I read it right the time. He shall cry
unto me, thou art my father, my God, and
the rock of my salvation. That's what it
says there.
No, you said you said ya, but anyway,
keep reading. Okay.
Also, I have uh also, I will make him my
firstborn, higher than the kings of the
earth.
Okay, so wait. David is the firstborn?
No, he's not, but he will make him.
Yes, so but how can he make him the
firstborn?
Hierarchy-wise, status. Because he's not
the first son
of Jesse. He's the youngest of eight,
and he's not the first king, right?
Correct. But he's still going to be the
firstborn, right? Correct. So, in what
way is he firstborn?
He's higher than all the other kings in
the earth.
>> You got it. So, it means supremacy. He's
supreme. Firstborn in terms of status as
being the one who's the supreme king
overall, right?
Correct. In this statement, yes.
Exactly. So, when Jesus said to be the
firstborn of all creation, doesn't mean
he's the first one created. It means he
is supreme over creation. Okay. He is
preeminent over creation. He's superior
to all creation because he created it,
sustains it, and it's his inheritance.
I see. Okay. So, he's not a creature.
You with me there? I do. I am with you
here. All right. So, this teaching that
they're deceiving you that Jesus
creature, get rid of it. Okay. No
problem. So now, that's the first thing.
What else do you believe about I mean
cuz I want to keep make sure that you
realize that
>> Yeah. Jesus is not a creature. He is not
the Father, not the Spirit, but he's one
with the Father and Spirit. He is God
Almighty who became flesh. I get You got
to get that part. Do you have any other
text that trouble you into thinking that
that's not who Jesus is so I can adjust
them?